Hey Thoughty2 here, let's have a peak inside
some of the most secretive places on earth.
Shrouded in mystery, dens for the rich and
powerful, where minds get together and hatch
shady plans.
These are the places you're just not aloud
to go.
Room 39
North Korea as a whole is a unnervingly secretive
place, but there's one room, in one building
that's the most secretive of all; Room 39.
Established in the late 1970s, Room 39 is
a government organisation, directly controlled
by the Kim family.
The goal of Room 39 is to seek underhanded
and malicious ways to illegally obtain foreign
currencies.
It is rumoured the organisation utilises 10
to 20 bank accounts in China and Switzerland
for the purposes of money laundering, counterfeiting
and general shady transactions.
It is widely speculated that Room 39 is deeply
involved in government controlled drug smuggling
and illicit weapon sales.
We know that the organisation has 120 foreign
trade companies under its jurisdiction.
Nobody knows how it got it's name, but the
Room itself is said to be located inside a
ruling Workers' Party building in the capital
city Pyongyang.
Club 33
Somewhat less malicious, but just as secretive
is Disneland's Club 33.
Club 33 is a strictly member's only club and
restaurant, discreetly located above the Blue
Bayou in New Orleans Square.
To become a member and step inside the notorious
doorway you will need about $30,000, but even
then there's a fourteen year waiting list.
There's a strict member limit of only 487
people.
The club has been frequented by presidents,
prime ministers, actors and billionaires.
It's the only place in Disneyland where you
can buy an alcoholic beverage.
Area 51
Located in southern Nevada, in the United
States, Area 51 is large secretive military
airfield, and arguably the most infamous and
controversial location in this video.
The use of lethal force is authorised if anyone
attempts to step foot inside the base's perimeter.
The base's primary function is to develop
and test experimental aircraft and weapons
systems.
However, because of the government's incredibly
tight grasp on the base's secrecy, Area 51
has been the subject of many UFO conspiracies.
Many believe the base is used to examine and
attempt to reverse engineer crashed alien
spaceships, alien technology, and even alien
lifeforms.
White's Gentlemen's Club
Founded in 1693 by Francesco Bianco, White's
is the most exclusive gentlemen's club in
existence.
White's is located in London, England and
gained a reputation for it's exclusivity and
often laddish behaviour of its members.
Women are completely banned from the club,
the only woman to have ever been entertained
by the club is Queen Elizabeth II.
The only way to become a member of the club
and step foot inside the door, is to first
be a man and second be invited by a current
member of the club, who has the support of
two other members.
Which, unless you're best buddies with a member
of the Royal family or a powerful politician,
isn't likely to happen.
Current notable members include Prince Charles
and Prince William.
British Prime Minister David Cameron was a
former member for 15 years, but resigned in
2008 because he disagreed with the club's
male-only policy.
The club is famous for its betting book in
which members make outrageous bets, such as
a £3,000 bet on which of two raindrops would
slide down the window first.
RAF Menwith Hill
Menwith Hill is a Royal Air Force base in
North Yorkshire, England.
The primary job of this mysterious RAF base
is to spy on and intercept enemy signals,
satellites and missiles.
The base has heavy connections with the global
ECHELON spy network, the ECHELON network is
a close-nit global spy alliance between the
United Kingdom, United States, Canada, Australia
and New Zealand.
RAF Menwith Hill is the largest electronic
monitoring station in the world and a lot
of its work is done on behalf of the US National
Security Agency.
Menwith Hill originally created during the
Cold War to spy on the Soviet Union and their
allies.
But it has since been used to spy on terrorists
and drug dealers.
It has even been used to monitor and gain
intelligence on foreign political and diplomatic
bodies.
Some believe it has been heavily involved
with commercial espionage and mass eavesdropping
on telephone and radio communications.
Mount Weather Emergency Operations Center
Deep in the forests of the U.S. state of Virginia
is a last resort base, setup incase an "end
of the world" situation ever arises.
Mount Weather Emergency Operations Center
was setup by FEMA, the Federal Emergency Management
Agency, it is where high profile individuals
and government officials will shelter from
the impending doom during an apocalypse.
Very little is known about the base because
it's details are highly classified, the base
is constantly protected by armed guards and
razor wire.
The complex consists of two extremely large
areas, Area A, which is above ground, contains
dormitories, a laboratory, a training area,
an on-site sewage treatment plant and two
water tanks holding 250,000 gallons of water,
amongst many other facilities, it is said
the complex is completely self-contained.
Area B is entirely underground, some believe
there is an entire self-sustaining city below
ground, that apparently consists of private
apartments, streets and sidewalks, cafeterias
and hospitals, a power plant, an underground
mass transit system and a TV network.
Mount Yamantaw
Mount Yamantaw is the tallest mountain in
the Ural mountain range in Russia, standing
at 1,640 metres (5,381 ft) tall.
In the local language, Mount Yamantaw means
"evil mountain".
The U.S. government strongly believe that
hidden deep within the mountain is a massive
stockpile of nuclear weapons housed in an
underground military facility.
There is a top secret town just south of the
mountain called Mezhgorye, the town is permanently
closed to the outside world some believe the
town contains a human civilisation employed
to develop nuclear weaponry.
The U.S. government has repeatedly asked Russia
what it's hiding there and their answers are
strangely inconsistent.
Over the years Russia have said it's a mining
site, a repository for Russian treasures,
a food storage area and last but not least
a bunker for leaders in case of a nuclear
war.
Come on Russia, make your mind up.